foreign
the Civil War hand-to-hand combat is
quite rare let alone a straight up sort
of uh wrestling melee that's going on in
the rain it just it struck me as a
little bit much I'm Gary Edelman I'm the
chief historian at the American
Battlefield trust and as a licensed
Battlefield guide at Gettysburg I give
tours at more than 50 battlefields today
we're going to be looking at American
Civil War battles in movies and judging
how real they are
thank you
right away what stands out is the
Gatling gun the Gatling gun was around
during a civil war but it was not used
in 1862 it was also not used in New
Mexico where this is really set you can
count on two hands the number of Gatling
guns that were actually used in the
Civil War and those used would have been
barely at Petersburg and occasionally on
Union Naval uh vessels
[Music]
thank you
the idea that these positions are
prepared in a battle that in reality
happened with nobody expecting it
they've got rivetted walls and mortar
guns and all this that stood out right
away as something a little crazy
[Music]
thank you
it's pretty realistic in that scene that
you see a lot of artillery fire not
exactly the artillery fire I would
expect they certainly weren't lugging
those heavy mortar guns with high arches
all the way through the New Mexico
desert in order to get to this place but
it's pretty realistic that they're
shooting with artillery at first because
they're really outside of the 250 or 350
yard range that is the effective range
of the shoulder carried rifled muskets
the idea of both sides charging power as
a melee into one another there weren't
800 soldiers on each side at the Battle
of Glorietta pass going over a 300 yard
sort of meeting in the middle that
sounds more like medieval days than the
Civil War
we actually have solid accounts of how
Civil War soldiers wired Bridges this
was often done by engineer soldiers
soldiers who understood explosives and
where to place them so that they could
use as little as possible get the job
done there they seem to be doing a
pretty good job in the movie wiring it
along where the peers and the main
supports were in order to make this
particular bridge collapse
foreign
soldiers on either side blowing up
Bridges during the Battle of Glory at a
past to affect some sort of a victory
battles were often fought over
Transportation facilities it was so
important to control Rivers and Roads
and railroads that Bridges were natural
targets of both armies during the Civil
War I would give this clip a two out of
10. the fact is that this is so wrong
that it's hard to attribute to any one
battle in this campaign
yeah
this battle of Ellisville sort of I
would call it more of a skirmish here
you have a substantial number of people
in a rural County sort of rising up to
secede from the south to rejoin the
union and capturing a county seat in the
meantime that's what we're seeing in
this scene
we do have examples of women joining
Union regiments sometimes dressed as men
sometimes just going into Camp to be
with their husbands sometimes actually
getting into battle you know as female
combatants
both sides used whatever they could
given the time and the materials they
had sometimes it was simple as using a
picket fence so an overturned wagon that
must have been a great way to stop some
particular bullets and if you had time
to deal with sandbags and digging up
Earthworks all the better
cannons are designed to fire particular
types of Ordnance it might be solid it
might explode in the air when it hits
the ground in front of you or it might
shoot something like grape shot or
canister and maybe lacking all that
that's what they're showing in the movie
is that in this battle or Skirmish they
put metal rods into their Cannon and
when you blow off a cannon it'll push
out whatever is in there
at that range that they show on the
scene those metal rods could have been
devastating to man and Beast I'm not
sure if they could have exactly blown up
the enemy ammunition chest that they are
apparently showing I would rate this a
seven
oh
I've been to Port Hudson several times
and anybody who both goes there and sees
the photographs from this place during
and after The Siege is impressed with
the extensive nature of the Confederate
fortifications it's a very difficult
place to try to conquer I would disagree
about the terrain they used for the
attack because it's basically in a swamp
it's just absolutely even nastier
terrain than you see there
soldiers were starting to not only
realize that if you could put some dirt
just two feet thick and maybe a few feet
tall that you're going to preserve life
to that why not revet that dirt with
logs why not put a head log on top so
you could shoot under that and have your
head protected while you shot while
you're at it why don't you put pointy
logs out as freestanding obstacles out
in front of your line
soldiers absolutely used what we call
Club muskets using their musket as a
club first of all if an enemy is coming
at you and you don't have time to take
out your bayonet a fix it to the front
and then thrust it at them you're simply
going to club that particular musket
I love that moment where there's a
soldier who is actually using his
bayonet against one of the other
soldiers and then he turns around and a
soldier in the back hands him a
pre-loaded gun it's all but impossible
to load a gun with the bayonet on the
end so that Soldier would have already
shot his bullet then put the bayonet on
there and confronted by a new enemy that
the guy behind him couldn't shoot at he
simply handed that rifle forward during
the Civil War Sometimes the best
shooters were up front and they had
loaders behind thems in the Battle of
Fredericksburg soldiers would have guns
lined up next to them pre-loaded that
they could just pop off against their
enemies
[Music]
Will Smith's characters and amalgamation
of a black soldier named Gordon who
self-emancipates and this other uh
soldier named whip Peter and it is a
true story I would rate this clip a six
out of 10.
[Music]
the stakes are high at the Battle of
Antietam for the South they're coming
off of a string of Victories it's
possible that if they win again maybe
the European powers will start
recognizing the Confederacy for the
north they're on the losing streak they
really need to turn back Robert E Lee's
powerful Confederate Army while they
have the chance and give Abraham Lincoln
the opportunity to issue his
Emancipation Proclamation changing
changing the purpose and direction of
the war
foreign
to be sure were cognizant of the horror
that tree limbs raining down onto troops
could cause among the morale and the
health of the troops attacking them so
absolutely they would sometimes shoot
into the trees with that deliberate idea
of wounding and demoralizing the enemy
the most seasoned commanders are going
to try to get their troops as close to
the enemy as possible before returning
fire and closing up their line and
shrinking their lines so that they
continue to be shoulder to shoulder
amidst the chaos of a battle and wait
until you got to the enemy to deliver a
killing blow
in an infantry line everybody has to be
a righty because if you shoot in two
ranks you've got two heads in front of
you and if you're right behind somebody
if you're a righty you're going to shoot
between the two heads in front of you if
you're a lefty that gun's going to go
straight into the head of the person in
front of you and butt up against the gun
to the person to your right and the
other thing you needed was a trigger
finger and you needed two front teeth in
order to tear off the cartridge to pour
the powder into your gun
night fighting in the Civil War is a
pretty rare thing the whole tactical
setup of the Civil War is to be able to
see things to be able to see your enemy
for your troops to be able to see your
flag it was hard to issue bugle commands
among the din of battles so line of
sight was very important but they fought
at night when they needed to and some of
the Battle of Fort Wagner was indeed
fought in the evening and and if I'm an
attacking Force I would love to have as
Colonel Shaw says we will advance under
cover of Darkness that's exactly what I
would do
[Music]
in the Battle of Fort Wagner you have
the most notable
combat with black soldiers up to that
time the 54th Massachusetts made it into
Fort Wagner but as many Civil War
soldiers found out getting into a place
and holding and controlling a place are
two very different things I'm going to
rate them a nine this one brought in a
lot of the elements you needed to
understand the scene to show what combat
was like in the Civil War is it perfect
no is it perfect enough yes
[Applause]
there is a battle called The Battle of
Jenkins ferry in Arkansas it was fought
in the rain in a in a field that had
begun to flood and if you're planning to
attack that enemy and maybe you are met
with a freak a ridiculously heavy
rainstorm maybe it's to your advantage
to attack them that way uh maybe they're
not using guns because you can't use a
gun when your powder is all wet
[Applause]
I don't think I've heard of an account
of somebody actually grabbing the
bayonet these things are pretty sharp
taking it off and immediately using it
but it's pretty cool for the movies
[Applause]
in the Civil War hand-to-hand combat is
quite rare with the artillery you're
going to fight at a distance and usually
when an enemy is you know 10 yards from
you you're going to try to run away
um so hand-to-hand combat it did happen
to be sure Club muskets bayonets Sabers
punching and kicking but it's pretty
rare to have it let alone a straight up
sort of uh wrestling melee that's going
on in the rain it just it struck me as a
little bit much I'm gonna rate this clip
of four out of 10. I adore this movie
but the the battle scene is pretty
ridiculous
thank you
if I'm in an open field I would be
tickled pink to have half my body
covered by some slats in a fence I would
prefer a big boulder don't get me wrong
but I'm going to be happy for anything I
can use that gives me more chance to
live and gives my troops a better chance
to repel the enemy
[Music]
once you've got the range of your weapon
they could be extraordinarily accurate
but hitting a moving Target laterally is
probably not easy for anybody except the
best Shooters certainly it's possible is
it unlikely uh you know that he could
make it through such a hail storm of
bullets yeah it seems pretty unlikely to
me they could have hit him while he was
resting he was definitely within easy
musket range at that point but the Civil
War produces hundreds of examples of
that man is too brave don't shoot him so
there was a gentlemanliness and an honor
is this the last one I don't know
there's no ether either
one of their greatest myths of the Civil
War is that Civil War surgeons are sort
of sawing through people's bones without
any sort of painkiller and no
preparation while they scream to their
surgeries only biting on a bullet or or
a stick or something like this and it's
just not true most of those amputations
were conducted with the use of morphine
or ether a substantial painkiller that
would allow surgeons to actually
carefully prepare for the actual
amputation by cutting away the muscle
leaving a skin flap and then sawing
through the bone with a soft so sharp
that it wouldn't take that long
amputation was the most common surgery
employed during the Civil War for good
reason surgeons of the time could not
deal with the complexities of internal
injuries on the Torso but you could turn
a wound to your extremities into
something they could treat by amputating
it at least there's no gangrene
where there will be if it doesn't come
off soon
the dreaded infection gangrene for which
the Civil War would start to produce a
cure actually medical advancements were
made you know very often with great
frequency during the Civil War but
surgeons understood the idea of
infection but they didn't have an
understanding of microbiology yet I'll
rate this clip a six out of ten
Gettysburg has sort of emerged as the
greatest battle of the Civil War and we
have a lot of good accounts about what
happened on little Roundtop the little
round top set in the movie is
extraordinarily accurate it lacked the
larger Boulders that are actually on the
hill today and the soldiers really
didn't have time to build a stone wall
until after the fighting but other than
that the open woods and the slope were
very close to what you could see today
send out word to take uh ammunition from
the wounded make every round count go
they come again ammunition is heavy and
both armies have a limited supply of it
if an enemy attacks you four five six
times as the Confederates did on little
round top the union would be naturally
running out of ammunition there's no big
Reserve train of ammunition anywhere
they'd already looked in the cartridge
boxes of their dead and wounded comrades
they were at the absolute end at that
point and there were no troops on little
round top until just a few minutes
before the actual fighting took place no
one had time to build the impressive
stone walls no one had time to really
Scout out the position and figure out
who's going to go where it was one
Brigade you know sort of placing
soldiers rather quickly before the
Confederates attacked these huge armies
end up meeting upon their flanks at
little Roundtop with basically equal
numbers it's something they showed
pretty well in the movie in terms of
numbers
Union had already repulsed five attacks
and they saw the southerners forming for
one more they were really out of options
and in a desperate moment their Colonel
Chamberlain you see him order the
bayonet we don't have bullets so let's
use the pointy Spears on the front of
our guns and charge down into them
left wing right wheel
[Music]
they did a simple military maneuver that
the movie spells out well for us the
union line the 20th main regiment was
sort of straight but then when the
Confederates came from this side they
sort of formed into almost a V at some
point as they wanted to fall upon the
Confederates they wanted to do this and
then this so in other words the left
wing of the regiment this is my left is
going to do a wheel so that they come
online with the rest of them at which
time the whole regiment would wheel down
the hill into the enemy and it worked I
would rate this clip a nine
[Music]
foreign
you see them sort of lighting the fuse
and then putting sandbags up because
they didn't want the explosion coming
back their way this actually happened
but one thing I really wish they could
have included was that they lit the fuse
and waited five ten minutes and nothing
happened and then they had to remove the
sandbags and the bravest man in the
world had to go into that shaft and find
out where it had broken and splice it
and light that thing again and run back
out and it worked
all right
the unit had made careful plans for this
attack and part of that plan is of
course to get the the Union Soldiers as
close to the coming crater as possible
so that they're going to cross the least
amount of ground as possible before they
were on top of the enemy
the ferocity of the blast ripping
clothes off of people so many would have
been just absolutely disintegrated you
know in the initial blast I think it's
something like 300 South Carolinians
just gone
run
[Music]
[Applause]
this idea of the turkey shoot they've
got themselves trapped in their own hole
is true but not like you see it in the
movie first of all the attack into the
crater was part of a much larger attack
with Union Soldiers really exploiting
some of their gains over the course of
an hour or so the Confederates are able
to muster soldiers from another part of
the battlefield that were able to come
and then sort of push the Union Soldiers
back and shoot down upon those Union
Soldiers at the same time so they
weren't exactly surrounding the Union
Soldiers who were hapless inside the
crater some were in there to be sure but
other soldiers are on both sides of the
crater as well
this idea of using a gun as a spear at
the right moment absolutely documented
during the Civil War
there's a real Health concern about
leaving man and beasts rotting on the
lines you're supposed to occupy they
showed a confederate soldier grabbing a
belt buckle off of a dead Union soldier
because this is something that would
happen regularly one thing the union had
was more of almost everything the South
needed and that also went for textiles
so after a battle either side would have
rooted through the enemy debtor wounded
others saw the need of the moment like I
need to keep my pants up and I need a
new belt buckle and I think that's what
we're seeing there in that scene I would
give it a five some of it's so overdone
it's such a dramatic scene but it's very
effective outside of its accuracy
foreign
the blockade is sort of the unsung hero
for the union of the Civil War they
would blockade all the southern ports
preventing them from getting the things
they needed to wage the war it took a
while but eventually the blockade worked
and the South had real trouble getting
things from Europe or from anywhere as
the war went on and they couldn't
produce it all themselves but that
blockade wouldn't have been on the
outskirts of Richmond Virginia these
were on the North Atlantic Ocean and in
the Gulf of Mexico really blocking
places like Wilmington North Carolina
and uh and Mobile Alabama but all those
places had fallen by then anyway so the
blockade was almost a non-issue
the emergence of Ironclad vessels
changed the face of warfare forever the
days of the wooden ship were quickly
ending after March of 1862 when iron
ships started fighting against each
other this is something the clip did
pretty well it showed pretty accurately
a Confederate iron-clad vessel that
would have had thick plates of iron in
this Fashion on the outside and they
correctly showed the way that it was
designed to Ricochet projectiles coming
toward it
artillery on a ship is often on a track
so that it could handle the substantial
recoil necessary from such a large
charge of powder but you would load it
Tamp it down and then move the gun back
out through the well Ironclad vessel had
a good number of cannons you know
sticking out of the ports
so you have a few vulnerabilities on the
ship I mean if you hit that Rudder
suddenly this ship can't steer anymore
secondly you have these ports where the
guns stick out which could be opened or
closed as necessary if you get a
projectile in there especially an
exploding projectile you're going to do
substantial damage inside the ship third
if you can hit the Pilot House you can't
see from inside those ships except out
of that Pilot House
[Music]
this battle is being fought in Richmond
Virginia as Richmond is burning the
Confederate Army is fleeing at this
point and it's not till the next day and
the day after that the union really
started occupying these areas and
capturing the cities the union has just
can and after Canon and regiments of men
on the shoreline ready to batter this
Confederate Cannon I mean this is
absolutely ridiculous at least that
close to Richmond uh that they would be
set up for such an engagement if
anything the union controlled the rivers
um you know further uh Downstream so if
anything the union would have had Naval
vessels going against them I would rate
this clip of four I guess I would call
this clip cool and a lot of fun but not
a whole lot of accurate history there my
favorite Civil War battle scene that I
watched today was definitely Glory it
barely edges out Gettysburg Glory just
has all the drama you've got the attack
you've got the charge you've got some
historical accuracy it's just so well
done and although I've seen it 50 times
already it was enjoyable to watch again
and if you enjoyed this why not click
above for another video